what if i told you that most if not all
of your online existence is fake
the articles you read the twitter
accounts you follow even this video
you're watching right now it's all
fiction created by artificial
intelligence whose job is to keep you
clicking on content that doesn't matter
and keep you buying products that you
don't need
you me everyone we're living in a real
life matrix designed to distract you
from the truth that we're just drones in
a digital anthill we live work and die
so that the wealthy and powerful can
grow more wealthy and powerful this is
called the dead internet theory and
there's some compelling evidence that
it's real
let's find out why
[Music]
the core premise of the dead internet
conspiracy says that most internet
content and the consumers of that
content are fake they don't exist so how
much content on the internet is actually
created by ai actually it's more than
you think studies say that only about 50
percent of web traffic is human and that
number is going down every year in 2013
the times reported that half of youtube
traffic was bots masquerading as people
and this was so scary that youtube
employees were worried about an
inflection point where their algorithms
would be so overwhelmed by bot traffic
that they couldn't tell what was real
eventually seeing actual human traffic
as fake they called this event the
inversion
ominous it is i see these bots on this
channel but most days i get 10 or 20
comments it should be more it should but
that's not my point but sometimes i wake
up and i've got a thousand comments and
they're all very generic comments posted
by people with very generic usernames
and they're not watching the videos
subscribers to this channel watch 60
even 100 of each video you people who
watch 100
we salute you we do but the bots they're
watching for 10 seconds and then leaving
a weird comment and then moving on to
watch another video for 10 seconds when
i look at the channel's stats after a
wave of bots it's like locusts it's
swift and it's destructive
so why is this happening what's it about
money
take facebook yeah do we have to we do
it's been alleged that facebook has been
overstating its reach and
misrepresenting its data for years in
2018 a facebook product manager emailed
colleagues that their metrics are quote
unquote a lawsuit waiting to happen what
happened a lawsuit
i see what you did there it's a class
action suit filed by facebook
advertisers they claim that facebook
overestimates its traffic by between 150
and 900 percent now facebook claims they
only overstate their traffic by
60 to 80 percent either way it's fake
traffic it's fake traffic but the money
facebook collects from advertisers
that's real money if you're a business
and you spend money on online ads you
want your ads viewed by actual people
not viewed like this
oh what the hell am i looking at this is
a chinese click farm hundreds or
thousands of bots are currently clicking
on videos leaving comments creating
engagement row after row of smartphones
watching videos and more importantly
watching the ads now the platforms know
this is happening but they aren't in a
rush to change it according to the
leaked emails facebook knows that there
are millions of duplicate accounts on
the platform but it leaves them active
on purpose an internal analysis claimed
that removing fake accounts would cause
a drop of 10 or more of facebook's
numbers is that a lot
well last year facebook took in 84
billion dollars in ad revenue that's
actually grotesque
i agree facebook is not going to give up
10 percent or even 1 percent of that
money the numbers are too large this is
billions of dollars now to be fair
facebook says these allegations are
without merit and we will defend
ourselves vigorously
but
mere hours after the lawsuit was made
public
facebook changed its policy to say
potential customer reach is an estimate
not a guarantee of actual customer reach
your mileage may vary exactly
so bots for profit totally predictable
but is it darker than that it's darker
according to the dead internet theory
much darker
like so many good conspiracy theories
the dead internet theory started out in
some of the darker corners of the web
places like 4chan wizardchan and agora
road the first person to put a name to
it goes by the online handle illuminati
pirate name checks out the theory goes
like this sometime around 2016 the
internet started becoming sterilized and
homogenized content that was always
generated by humans was now being
generated by ai bots and the bots are
subtle they're designed to sound human
and blend into the background but if we
look a little more closely eerie
patterns seem to emerge on twitter
there's a type of account that uses a
certain formula first the profile
pictures aren't people they're usually
anime characters or hearts or stars or
other generic looking icons and the
colors are soft usually pink purple or
light blue posts are short written in
all lowercase and contain the same kind
of message i'm young i have a crush i
enjoy simple things i am optimistic but
most of all i'm relatable people who
believe the dead internet theory say
they've been seeing the same content
repurposed over and over for years
supermoon right every year we're slammed
with articles about the super moon
murder hornets murder hornets every year
climate change oh climate change is real
you believe anything that's for another
time so why why is content on the
internet so bland and repetitive
well according to the dead internet
theory and this is a quote it's because
the us government is engaging in an
artificial intelligence-powered
gaslighting of the entire world
population get my tinfoil head
coming up
the original post about the dead
internet theory says that a few online
influencers are working with
corporations and the united states
government in order to manipulate our
behavior and manipulate how we think
well as far as social media platforms go
this is true take facebook again hey let
me ask you is facebook evil uh they're
very profitable you didn't answer my
question no
on facebook you're shown posts that
you're likely to engage with so politics
wise you're going to be shown an
overwhelming amount of content that
supports your worldview which keeps you
on the platform which keeps you clicking
on ads
and you're also going to be shown
political posts that make you angry
prompting you to respond which keeps you
on the platform
and keeps you clicking on ads you won't
see a lot of posts saying you know i may
disagree with your opinion but i respect
and support your right to have that view
now let's discuss the issues on which we
actually agree of which there are many
facebook profits by having you produce
dopamine which keeps you clicking and
cortisol and adrenaline which keeps you
clicking how does facebook know what
content keeps you on the platform well
you tell them all the time with every
link you click every site you visit and
how long you spend on those sites now
don't take my word for it here's mark
zuckerberg i wish i could keep telling
you that our mission in life is
connecting people
but it isn't
we just want to predict your future
behaviors
spectre showed me how to manipulate you
into sharing intimate data about
yourself and all those you love for free
the more you express yourself
the more we own you he said that well
technically no but that's exactly what
facebook does which leads to another
part of the dead internet theory i'm
confused well that wasn't mark
zuckerberg that was a deep fake which is
a computer-generated video made to look
like a human and deep fakes they're
getting good i'm gonna show you some
magic
it's the real thing
i mean uh
it's all
the real
thing
even tom cruise as a tic tac yeah that
wasn't tom cruise deep fake deep fake
the technology uses artificial
intelligence to sort through hundreds or
thousands of images to find frames that
match the actual person in the video but
millions i mean millions of people
thought those videos were real well
we're not crazy enough to trust
zuckerberg
are we and nobody's crazy enough to
trust an actor
do right
that's why you're here
but what about a deep fake from a
trusted world leader president trump is
a total and complete
now
you see i would never say these things
at least not in a public address but
someone else would now that video was a
joke and created by jordan peele but
what if in today's climate someone
released a video of a politician saying
something racist or radical the media
would believe it well of course the
media would believe it they believe
everything a deep fake is a computer
simulation of a real person and people
are fooled by that but what about a
computer simulation of a completely
artificial person
could people be fooled by that yeah i
don't like where this is going
michaela souza is an instagram
influencer with over 3 million followers
lil michaela as she's known is a
brazilian-born model who posts about her
glamorous la lifestyle photo shoots
product endorsements and all the typical
bumper sticker social activism that
instagram models are known for she
sounds pretty hollow well how's this for
hollow in 2018 michaela's account was
hacked and it was revealed that she was
completely fake computer generated no no
her fans couldn't believe it eventually
a media slash marketing company called
brud confessed that she wasn't real did
her fans abandon her nope since then
she's amassed about two million more
followers did he know she's fake well
some do most don't care and michaela
doesn't bring it up so this is dangerous
more dangerous than you think this is a
completely fake computer generated
character created by humans okay but
there is a piece of technology that is
completely autonomous runs on artificial
intelligence on its own and is
programmed to kill humans rising the
machines
there's a drone quadcopter called cargo
2 produced by a defense contractor stm
developed in turkey cargo 2 uses machine
learning to classify and identify
threats then completely on their own
swarms of drones working together will
attack their target according to the un
the drones are programmed to attack
targets without requiring an operator in
effect a true fire forget and find
capability they just analyze a bunch of
data and decide yes that's a murder
target without any human analyzing their
work
these things have killed people oh yeah
since 2018 they've been deployed by the
turkish military both foreign and
domestically it's currently killing
people in ukraine how many people were
wet well they won't say of course well
let's put these pieces together now as
the algorithms get better and better at
showing us content to keep us engaged
what's to stop those algorithms from
actually creating the content to keep us
engaged nothing nothing and isn't that
the natural progression of this a google
whistleblower has said that google has
algorithms that can write other
algorithms google's auto ml0 does
exactly this what does google say well
google says the allegations are false
that means it's definitely true look if
artificial intelligence can create
social media accounts attract millions
of followers generate billions of
dollars influence elections and drop
bombs on people all without human
intervention well the internet really is
dead and real living people people like
you and me are here to do nothing more
than feed it our money and our knowledge
so these systems can become smarter and
even more powerful now facebook is
launching metaverse will you experience
your entire life online through virtual
reality if you think online culture is
toxic now wait we're spending all of our
time there the metaverse is gonna make
us long for the good old days of the
matrix and where's neo when you need him
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor
subscribe like share comment all that
stuff really helps the channel the
algorithm has not been kind to us videos
like this don't help that's true but
with your help we can't overcome until
next time be safe be kind and know that
you are appreciated
[Music]
you